I'm against censorship I'm in favor of
you know free speech I'm almost a free
speech out absolutist you know I think
if you don't like something you don't
have to buy it you know where television
is full of channels that I have no
interested in there's you know I I get a
satellite TV thing and I got like 20
shopping channels I've never bought
anything off a shopping channel I never
intend to buy anything off a shopping
channel it also has a 20 Christian
channels I'm not interested in them
either but I don't want them taken off
the air I don't go ah these Christian
channels I hate them get rid of them
censor them the government should stop
all these Christian channels let them
have their channels if you want a
Christian channel there it is if if you
want a channel that has pornography on
it there's a channel it is pornography
on it if you want to channel this full
of right-wing people ranting you have
Fox if you want a channel that has more
of a left-wing slant there there are
those two like MSNBC we can have all the
channels we want it's like newspapers or
books so there shouldn't be any
censorship put all this stuff out there
I mean John Milton said it
centuries ago an area of legit akella
truth and falsehood grapple and free and
open encounter I do think that to get to
a one specific issue that is something I
was raised about our show but that is
really part of a larger issue that the
sexual attitudes in America are really
need to be liberalized I mean it's
ridiculous that there's still half the
population in America goes crazy if they
see a female breasts on television as
happened in the in the Superbowl you
know we have thousands of years of human
history in which people have seen female
breasts they're there you know you go to
Italy and they're statues of naked women
everywhere on the streets by you know
Michelangelo and other people and naked
angels and their breasts are all of them
and I think your television has breasts
on it if I'm not not mistaken you know
and then nobody goes crazy about it but
you know we show the Superbowl and Janet
Jackson's blood slips there and and
suddenly it's a national scandal as well
anybody's talking about for four months
so that's crazy and the fact that there
are breasts in HBO's in in my show
that's fine I'm all in favor of that
well I think that HBO in in the market
at least HBO had a lot to do with it and
then premium cable you know we broke
down the marketing I mean up to a
certain point even as recently as the
80s and 90s when I was working primarily
in television there were just four
networks and they were all over the air
so they're going into every home in
America you turn on your television
there are these four networks and they
they were reaching for a general
audience they felt the need to be
extremely safe but with cable television
and with the proliferation of cable
channels and then premium cable channels
which you don't even get what you're
bringing I think you'd have to go out
and specially buy that you could do more
adult fare you could do more niche fare
you didn't have to appeal to everybody
you could do something that you knew
would shock some people and disturb some
people but that other people would would
want and would pay money for and would
enjoy so you sort channels with higher
sexual content you saw channels with
greater violent content and now you'd
have like 50 places you can sell a
television show and all of them have
different parameters and and different
guidelines but HBO was really one of the
first ones and one of the most important
ones in in breaking those previous
taboos and doing it which shows like The
Sopranos and Deadwood and Rome which in
many ways a precursor I don't know if
you saw that show not but it was that
was an incredible show chills I don't
know if you should be happy when they
die but you know it you should certainly
be affected I mean if a character and a
work of fiction dies
and you don't care then that work of
fiction has failed on some level it's
not engaging you emotionally and fiction
is all about emotion if we just want to
engage in an intellectual analysis or
argument we can we can read nonfiction
it's really a better tool for that
fiction is meant to engage us on a very
primal emotional level we we want to
laugh we want to weep we want to feel
feel the strong emotions there we want
to fall in love even with its character
it was just a construction on a page and
so when a character dies you should feel
something just as you do in life I mean
and the fact that so many people were so
distraught at the red wedding or when
they died that's uh I take that as a
sign that I succeeded in what I and what
I set out to do and I even wanted to
give the readers a bit of pause when the
so-called villains died I mean I don't
know if you're up-to-date with the books
or the TV show but you know to refer to
some specifics you know when when
Joffrey dies during his own wedding
you know if you read that scene in the
book he's younger in the book he's only
13 years old and there are moments there
at the end as much as you hate that
character
there are moments there at the end and
you're seeing a through Tyrians eyes
where he's seeing a thirteen year old
boy in terror dying before his eyes and
reaching out to his mother and to his
his uncle Tyrion you know help me just
save me I can't be saved but you should
feel that too if only for a brief
fleeting moment when you're not jumping
up and down saying yes the bastards dead
but you should feel both both emotions
because life is complex like that and
when Tyrion confronts his father in the
final scene of the season and kills that
I said tragedy as much as it is a moment
of catharsis here it's it's
the failure it's that it's the ultimate
family dysfunction the family breaking
down into the worst possible way